hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today's
big idea is kind of a payoff I know that
in the last couple of videos we did
ideas that were heavily mathematical we
did a video on geometry and topology
then we did a video on symmetries which
is of course based in physics but what
we talked about was the mathematical
language in which we describe symmetries
the language of group theory so today we
get the payoff today we're gonna show
why we had to do those other two videos
you know we love math nothing wrong with
math but we're really about the ideas
that describe the physical world the
physics ideas and today's idea is gauge
Theory gauge theory is very directly
thus basically you should be able to
think of it as geometry we're not gonna
get too much into kepala G today but
we'll get there eventually geometry
wedded to symmetry that's what gauge
Theory is all about you may have heard
the phrase gauge Theory gauge theories
are at the center of modern quantum
field theory the standard model of
particle physics is a gauge Theory gauge
symmetries are gauge theories are
theories that have a certain kind of
symmetry that gives rise to fields that
give rise to forces of nature that's
what we're gonna go why are they called
gauge theories there's this story that
it has to do with railroads somehow
there is this this technique back in the
old days in the early 20th century that
you would have a gauge a literal sort of
physical measuring rod that they would
use in building the railroads to make
sure everything lined up correctly of
course it doesn't matter how big your
gauges as long as you use the correct
numbers of them to get from point A to
point B in other words it's just like
saying it doesn't measure it doesn't
matter whether you measure a distance in
centimeters or inches okay as long as
you get the same physical distance and
so this idea was picked up by Hermann
vile a mathematical physicist in the
20th century who talked about the
invariance under scaling and how that
could give rise to forces of nature and
that that terminology was adopted into
gauge theories but the gauges were
talking about the gauge theories were
talking about have nothing to do with
scaling we're not gonna be making things
bigger or smaller we're gonna be
rotating things together that's the
modern way
that we generally have gauge theories
showing up in particle physics in fact
the most obvious example to look at just
to fix their ideas are quarks we talked
about quarks a little bit quarks are
what make up the matter particles that
make up protons and neutrons and heavier
particles and and some lighter particles
so for example the proton we said is two
up quarks and a down quark the neutron
is two down quarks and an up quark
there are also mesons like the PI on
that is a quark and an antiquark etc
okay but the extra fact about quarks
that really makes them different than
the non quarks the leptons the electron
the muon the Tau the neutrinos and so
forth is that quarks come in three
colors of course the idea of colors
let's say red green and blue there was a
brief movement movement to make it red
white and blue but that was considered a
little jingoistic so red green and blue
was a little bit more physics oriented
this is an idea from Murray Gillman the
famous physicist he was one of the
co-inventors of quarks and the idea is
that there's not just one a pork field
for example there's just one electron
field basically but there are three
different up quark fields a red one a
green one and a blue one
again not actually red green and blue if
you shone light at them they would not
reflect red green or blue they're just
labels okay
just a way of saying there's a
multiplicity of three different kinds of
every single quark so we could imagine
drawing a little vector space it's not
just that there are three quarks there's
a red a green and a blue it's that every
quark is some combination of red green
and blue some linear combinations we can
imagine here is the actual quark field
it's living somewhere in this space of
red green and blue that's the idea okay
electrons do not have that color
property but quarks do and so you will
not be surprised to learn that whether
you're you call any particular quark red
or green or blue doesn't matter in fact
it doesn't matter if you call it some
linear combination of red green and blue
all the matters is that the relative
relationship between
different quarks is going to be
important but the actual value for the
color of any quark doesn't matter so
there is a symmetry oops I should be
consistent here color wise there is a
symmetry and the symmetry is rotations
of these three different colors of
quarks into each other it doesn't matter
how we oriented the axes in these
three-dimensional space also quark
fields like all other matter Fermi on
fields in nature whether it's electrons
or neutrinos or whatever are
complex-valued fields so in fact it's a
complex rotation and we talked about
that in the last video the symmetry here
is su 3 the unitary group the special
unitary group of three different complex
vectors rotating into each other so
there's an su 3 symmetry built into the
quark Fields and in fact there's this
it's a complicated history because
there's an entirely different su 3
symmetry which we eventually realized
was a symmetry between up quarks down
quarks and strange quarks this is only
an approximate symmetry it's not really
as good but it was still crucially
important in understanding particle
physics in the 60s that's called a
flavor symmetry for some reason up down
and strange are flavors there you go
whereas this is a color symmetry so
sometimes you see it written as SU 3
color and this is the one that is going
to be crucially important this is the
actual one that enters the standard
model of particle physics in a
fundamental way this is the relationship
for each quark for the up quark it can
come in red green and blue the down
quark comes in red green and blue the
strange quark comes in red they all do
okay all six of them and now when you
have a symmetry like that there's a
basic basic choice you need to make
there's two different ways that a field
theory can have a symmetry like su 3 or
whatever depending on what kind of
fields you have one way is to say look I
can rotate in this field space in this
color space in red green and blue space
there's a way that I have of just
rotating everywhere in the universe
because remember these are fields right
they live at certain locations in space
no sorry let's say it the other way
around
every location in space there's a value
of the fields so the question that we're
asking now is how do you rotate in color
space at different points in space at
the same time okay
so one option is you rotate globally
that is to say you have an ocean an idea
of what it means to rotate a fixed
amount let's say red gets rotated into
blue okay you rotate around the green
axis you rotate by a fixed amount
everywhere through space exactly the
same way okay that is called a global
symmetry and actually the flavor
symmetries are like that so the flavor
symmetry between up down and strange
quarks is that something that just makes
sense everywhere in space you know
whether the quarks are up-down or
strange you can change your definition
globally all throughout space and that's
useful that's helpful that's their you
know helps you sort of classify what the
field theory is doing what kinds of
particles can be made what kinds of
interactions there are okay but there's
a much more powerful idea which is that
you can rotate locally and what that
means this is when you actually get what
we call a gauge theory what that means
is that I can separately at one point in
space rotate my red green and blue axes
into each other and at another space I
can rotate in a completely to the point
in space I can rotate in a completely
different way so in other words to draw
a picture here is space you know we're
getting good at drawing space now and
here's a point in space and at some
point in space I have three little axes
corresponding to red green and blue at
some other point in space I have axes
corresponding to red green and blue and
the gauge symmetry the local symmetry
says that it is an invariance of the
theory that I can change red green blue
I can rotate them at one point under
some su3 transformation and at another
point at each other point in space I can
rotate them completely separately okay
so I might have a quirk that I said was
blue over here and over here the same
quark field is green or something like
right and the point is it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter at every point this is
a much bigger symmetry right so
scientists physicists will sometimes say
su3 is an eight dimensional group right
because we said N squared minus one is
the dimensionality of SU n and if you
have a global symmetry that's exactly
correct you have an eight dimensional
symmetry group there's eight different
things you can do when you have a local
symmetry a gauge symmetry the true
symmetry group is infinite dimensional
because it is a separate su three
rotation at every point in space and
there an infinite number of points in
space so the mathematicians look at the
physicists and go like you clearly have
an infinite dimensional group here but
that's because we've suppressed the
dependence on spatial location and are
just thinking about the SU three
transformations okay that's what a gauge
Theory purports to be it's a theory
where there is a symmetry where that
symmetry can be separately a rotation at
every point in space but like we said
you might want to say okay here I have
some kind of quark Q what is important
is not whether that quark is red green
or blue that doesn't make any difference
at all that's a complete choice of
labels okay it has no physical effect
but I might have another quark over here
I'm trying to choose colors that are not
red green or blue
here's another quark over here I might
want to compare that quark field value
to that quark field value and like they
might one way to say like how are they
interacting or something like that right
so one way to do that would be to
parallel transport the court field along
some curve through space some trajectory
and say like what do I get at the end of
the travel transporting in other words
once I have a gauge symmetry I need to
be able to compare the values of quark
fields at different points in space even
though I can separately change the
labels at those different points in
space right whether a quark is red green
or blue in one space is completely what
point is completely up to me whether
it's red green or blue at another point
it's also completely up to me separately
so I need some way to physically say are
they the same color are they different
colors or whatever and in order to do
that I need to be able to parallel
transport the quarks we talked about
parallel transport in the geometry in
topology video two ideas ago parallel
transport is just keeping a vector
constant parallel to what it was as you
move it along some curve okay and to do
that you need what you need to be able
to know what it means to keep a vector
constant as you move it along a curve is
a connection field the connection is
exactly the set of data at every point
in space which answers the question what
does it mean to keep a vector constant
so if you want to gauge theory if you
want to gauge symmetry if you want to be
able to separately rotate the color
fields at one point in space and another
one but you also need to be able to
compare them it follows logically that
you need another field you need a new
field you need not only the quark fields
you also need a connection field that
tells you how to relate Kork fields at
different points in space okay so that
connection field or sometimes more and
more often it's going to be called a
gauge field and this extra field over
and above the quarks this extra field
that allows you to implement the gauge
symmetry is what's going to give rise to
forces to forces of nature in this case
in the case of su3 it's gonna give rise
to the strong force to what we call in
this case quantum chromo dynamics
because it is the quantum theory of the
dynamics of the color fields aka QCD so
it's really the dynamics it's really the
fact that the you need so you have these
fifties axes red green and blue I'm
telling you you're allowed to rotate
them however you want that implies the
existence of a gauge field connection
that lets me parallel transport and that
connection will have its own dynamics
and it's the dynamics of that connection
field which is going to give rise to the
strong nuclear force to QCD okay
in fact
it turns out that this is in fact how
nature works that all the forces of
nature work this way one way or the
other there are four forces that we like
to talk about and by the way sometimes
people try to get sticky about what you
mean by the definition of the word force
in this context the word force made
perfect sense and we're doing classical
mechanics and F equals MA
here in the context of quantum field
theory it makes much less sense there is
no fundamental notion of the word force
we just use the word informally to refer
to these four gauge theories that we
have lying around so if people say well
does the Higgs count as a force this
neutrino exchange counters of force does
the Pauli exclusion principle count as a
force who cares I don't care whether
they're forces or not they exist
they're real features of the world so
are these that's all I care about so we
know what the four forces the the
standard four forces are
electromagnetism these are all gauge
forces in some sense electromagnetism
you know we worked out electromagnetism
back in the 1800s right Maxwell and
their friends and in fact they invented
Maxwell knew about what we would now
call gauge transformations he didn't use
that language obviously but now with
real quantum field theory it's a much
more powerful thing so let the electron
field be denoted sy e - as a function of
X okay so lowercase I so it's not a wave
function it's a classical field that
will go into making the wave function
but I don't want to call it e because
you know we have Euler's constant like
it goes into e to the I theta that's
gonna be important in a second so I
don't want to call it easy so let's just
call it size of U - this is the electron
field and there is a u1 it's a complex
valued okay it's complex
so there is a u 1 symmetry of the
electron field that sends sy e minus of
X 2 e to the I theta and theta also
depends on x times sy e - of X so in
other words remember we talked about u1
back in the symmetry video last
week you want assist a rotation in the
complex plane so the electron field is a
complex number in fact it has other
indices it's more complicated than that
but it's a complex field okay
so I basically take that complex value
of the field and I rotate it by an angle
theta and I can rotate it separately by
a different angle theta at every point
in space so the whole theory is supposed
to be symmetric invariant under these
rotations by this value of theta which
is completely up to me theta is itself a
different value theta is not a physical
field it's just the way I'm changing the
what I call the real part and the
imaginary part of the of the electron
field at every point in space so that
implies the existence of a photon field
and usually in the lingo in the quantum
field theory literature that's denoted a
or mu the lowercase mu is an index
because it's a space-time vector the
photon field points in a certain
direction I want to try to simplify our
lives I don't know how well this is
gonna work what I was gonna call it
gamma of X because photons are given the
letter gamma in particle physics and I'm
gonna forget about the indices forget
about all of that the point is this is
the connection okay that's what the
photon field is it's the connection in
the u 1 symmetry of the complex
rotations of the electron field that's
what it is that's why we have
electromagnetism because there is a
gauge symmetry and in a word two
parallel transport to the electron field
from one point to another
we need a connection and that connection
is a separate field with its own
dynamics and we call it the photon that
is a way of thinking about why
electromagnetism exists at all ok then
that's one force of nature we have
another force called the strong force
strong nuclear force but you know it's
inside the nucleus not between nuclei
these days and that's QCD that's what we
just talked about so that is an su 3
gauge symmetry a separate su 3 rotation
at every point so I'm not gonna so
because now there are three
cork fields right for every for every
kind of cork for every flavor of pork
like up there's a red a green and a blue
so there's again indices and you need a
matrix to sort of rotate them into each
other let's just not go there this is we
don't need all those complications but
what we need is the fact that there is
an Associated connection field so the
connection for QCD is called the gluon
field and just like there are three
different colors of quarks there are
eight different gluons why are there
eight different gluons can you think
about it because su3 is an eighth
dimensional group that's why there's
eight different kinds of gluons
so one gluon field for every different
way that you can rotate the quark fields
into each other so again this is this is
a specific version of what what we call
yang-mills theories the yangon mills see
and yang and arm mills in the 1950s took
electromagnetism which is a u 1 gauge
theory they'd figure that out by I'll
probably vial figure that out and Yang
and mill said well look we know there
are these more complicated groups these
non abelian groups
remember we said abelian meant that a
symmetry has the property that it
doesn't matter how you do one rotation
versus another the order of operations
does not matter if you're non abelian
though and for you one that's the case
if I'm just rotating around a circle it
doesn't matter whether I rotate by five
degrees and then ten degrees or if I
rotate by ten degrees and then five
degrees so can you get the same answer
but if I'm in multiple dimensions I can
rotate around one axis and then another
and suddenly it does matter which order
I do it ends you get a non abelian group
so Yang and Mills were the ones who
proposed this idea that there could be
non abelian gauge groups which would
lead give rise to forces of nature we
didn't know what the groups were we
didn't know what the forces were at the
time so it was um Nambu and
Gelman and fridge and other people who
first put together the actual su3 gauge
theory that is the strong interactions
quantum chromodynamics in other words
when we have the weak force the weak
interactions are more complicated and
the reason why they're more complicated
is because of spontaneous symmetry
breaking okay so we'll get to that but
the actual way the standard model of
particle physics works out is this
beautiful intricate complex structure
that you know you look at it and it kind
of looks ugly and clutched together but
then you play with it you realize in
some sense it's the most general thing
like given certain constraints given
certain symmetries etc the standard
model is what it is it couldn't have
been anything else so it's kind of
beautiful in that weird sense it's a
beautiful thing once you learn to
appreciate it so for our purposes right
now all we're gonna say is that you can
think of the weak interactions as
rotations of the two-dimensional space
that can be spanned by let's say up
quarks and down quarks okay so not three
different colors of quarks which are
true for each up or down but rotating up
and down quarks into each other that's
what the SU that's what the weak
interactions do so that is an su 2 gauge
theory because the gauge there you can
do it separately everywhere and every
different point in space the up and down
quarks are themselves
complex so it's an su 2 gauge Theory
rather than so2 or something like that
and it's not just up and down it's also
other what we call doublets weak
doublets so the electron and the
electron neutrino are another weak
doublet and there's other different
copies again there's complications here
because of symmetry breaking but this is
the basic idea here so I just need to
say this out loud is always gonna bug me
um these don't look like there's a
symmetry between them everyone knows
which is the electron which is the
neutrino okay the electrons are
negatively charged neutrino is uncharged
it's neutral the up quark is charged
plus two-thirds the down quark is
charged minus one-third they have
different masses so the quark colors red
green and blue all three colors are
really exact
we the same in every way because of the
symmetry relating them here this looks
awkward because the up and down quarks
are not the same they different masses
different charges the electron and
neutrino are not the same different
masses different charges that's because
the symmetry is broken okay I just gotta
get that off my chest the symmetry is
there but it's hidden from us so it's
not manifest in this way of writing
things down
finally there's gravity now you might
have been told the gravity is a theory
of the geometry of space-time we talked
about geometry we haven't really talked
about gravity in any detail yet but we
talked about geometry we talked about
the fact that there's a metric that lets
you measure distances along curves or
areas or volumes and so forth there's
also a connection in space-time that
lets you move vectors parallel transport
them along curves and there's a
relationship you can derive the
connection from the metric so up here
there is just the connection this is an
internal symmetry okay the symmetry is
in this internal space it's not pointing
in different directions in space-time at
every point in space-time you can do the
rotation but what you're rotating is not
the directions of space-time themselves
it's this internal made up fictitious
space red green and blue so here there
is a connection but there's no metric
there's no distances there's just a way
of comparing vectors by parallel
transporting them here in space-time you
have both you have both a metric and a
connection and that's what makes it much
more complicated because again
everything there's this theorem that you
know the world arranges itself to be as
complicated as possible for graduate
students in theoretical physics so
there's the electromagnetic force the
strong force the weak force and gravity
they're all in some sense gauge theories
but they're all different this is fun
but also a little bit annoying okay what
is the gauge group so this this idea was
actually first proposed by our rukia MA
in the 50s 50s something like that soon
after yangon Mills proposed non abelian
gauge theories Judy Amma says well let's
think of gravity listening general
relativity as a gauge theory and he said
that it could be the gauge group was so3
comma one
what is that well you know we talked
about rotations right s o n is the
rotations of n real vectors space time
is four-dimensional so you might think
that the gauge group of space-time is
so4 because you can rotate things
together but a little bit of reflection
makes you think wait a minute I can't
just rotate space and time into each
other in the same way there's a slight
difference there right what I can do is
boost I can change the velocity at which
I look at space and time I can change my
reference frame so there is a slight
difference in space time between the
time like direction and the space like
directions so this is what so3 comma 1
means it means there are three
dimensions of space and one dimension of
time and this is actually the group of
transformations you can do at a point in
space-time it turns out that for
technical reasons this is not the best
way of thinking about general relativity
or gravity this is what is called the
Lorentz group Lorentz transformations
right
the Ren's transformations include
rotations in space as well as boosts
there's also the punker a group I'm not
going to get the accent in the correct
direction but onry ponca Ray was a very
advanced mathematician he knew about the
group theory that was being developed
was hot stuff back then and the Pont
gray group is the Lorentz group so the
rents group is rotations and boosts plus
translations translations are just you
move everything either in space or in
time and it turns out again technical
reasons but it's best to think of
gravity as a gauge theory of the plunk
or a group not just the Lorentz group ok
it's all because space-time is special
unlike all these forces unlike
electromagnetism strong and weak nuclear
forces all which are internal symmetries
relating fields to each other at the
same point in space time gravity
actually is transformations of
space-time itself that's why it becomes
a little bit more
complicated we're not gonna talk about
this at all by the way we're not gonna
talk about gravity as a gauge theory or
anything like that I just want you to
know that is something you can talk
about and people have been talking about
it's unclear whether you get any benefit
from talking about it that way like
Einstein in back in 1915 invented the
theory and that's more or less a good
way of thinking about it okay I just
wanted to let you know that all four of
these forces of nature can be thought of
as gauge theories one way or the other
let's now shift gears and put it to work
a little bit okay let's actually make
some money off of the fact that there
are these symmetries so what do we know
we know that we have some quantum fields
we know that the quantum fields appear
in different forms they're complex some
of them are complex so they have you one
gauge symmetries some of them are
doublets so they have an S you to some
of them are Triplets of color so they
have an su 3 that's where the standard
model gauge group comes from we know the
existence of these gauge symmetries
itself implies new fields the connection
fields okay and the connection fields
give rise to physical particles oh yes I
forgot to tell you physical particles
for the weak interactions they are the W
and Z bosons so for electromagnetism the
photon strong force the gluons the weak
force the W and Z bosons are the
physical excitations physical vibrations
in the SU 2 connection field okay I mean
think about that you totally understand
that you understand that sentence
perfectly well W and Z bosons are the
physical excitation from vibrations in
the su to gauge field but you would not
have understood that sentence nearly
well enough nearly as well just a few
weeks ago progress is being made
okay maybe none of us understand it
perfectly don't don't be upset about
that all right but the existence of
these fields giving rise to interactions
giving rise to forces of nature comes
from the gauge symmetry that's the first
important lesson
the next important lesson is that the
existence of these symmetries places
suck an incredibly strong constraint on
what the theory actually is remember we
talked about effective field theories in
the in the idea lecture on
renormalization we made a big deal about
the fact that we could put a cutoff on
our quantum field theory we could admit
that we cannot extend it to arbitrarily
high
jeez and then you might think that there
is an infinite number of terms in the
defining equations of motion for your
fields right you need some equations of
motion to give dynamics to the fields
you're talking about and in fact the way
we do that is again through an action so
an action is the integral over time of
the Lagrangian which is the integral
over DT and space D 3x of the lagrangian
s'ti the garage density is a function of
fields and derivatives of fields so by
derivatives the fields we mean
derivatives affected time - respect to
space things like that so there is a
function but the hope the point is that
L is a function of Phi some field some
collection of fields at X and then
derivatives of Phi
I'll write it with the curly D because
they're partial derivatives derivatives
of Phi also add X so it is a function of
X if you have some particular field
configuration at every point there is a
value of Lagrangian associated with that
field configuration field configuration
through both space and time okay and so
as I said as I said when we talk about
effective field theories there's only a
finite number of terms that we will ever
write down in lagrangian up to some if
we only care about the relevant and
marginal operators in the theory the
relevant and marginal interactions in
the theory so that's really very very
helpful we only need to write down a few
kinds of ways to multiply fields
together and we have the most general
effective field theory we can possibly
write down and nevertheless there's a
lot of fields in the standard model so
you think that well ok there's still a
whole bunch of interactions I can write
down but you are saved by the existence
of these symmetries because there's an
extra requirement that every term in the
Lagrangian has to be individually but
that's that's that's too strong the
Lagrangian as a whole has to be
invariant
under the symmetries that you talked
about so if you have an su three
symmetry you should be able to do that
that symmetry transformation so let's
say su three sends some quark field to
some transformed quark field both these
are functions of X okay and when you
plug the transform quark field into the
Lagrangian you better get the same
answer even that is again technically a
little bit too strong it's the action
that needs to be invariant but usually
the action being invariant means the
Lagrangian of aerion usually the
Lagrangian being invariant means every
term is separately in Merrion that's not
exactly true but that's pretty close
okay so what is this how does this
actually you know make us money how does
how do we make some benefit off of this
so think about the electron field
electron field we said sigh e minus of X
and there's au 1 gauge symmetry which
sense I - oops - e to the I theta which
is itself a function of x times sine
okay you rotate in the complex plane by
a little bit so so imagine
contemplate that in your well sorry let
me just back up a little bit let's get
this exactly right this is this is
tricky the Lagrangian roughly speaking
is the kinetic energy minus the
potential energy okay
so as we go through I should actually
read my notes that I have here rather
than just sort of mouthing off as we go
through to try to construct our
Lagrangian we have to ask ourselves what
different kinetic energies can we have
what different potential energies can we
have and the difference between them is
roughly the kinetic energy is the thing
that depends on the time derivative how
quickly things are changing that's the
kinetic energy whereas the potential
energy just taint just depends on the
values of the fields themselves okay
there's no derivative
of the fields in there roughly speaking
so the kinetic energy how do you get a
kinetic energy for oops how do you spell
kinetic the kinetic energy for the
electron field we already knew like we
had that mr. Dirac told us that when he
invented the Dirac equation but now
we're gauging it right we're giving this
extra gauge symmetry it affects the the
kinetic energy of the electron field a
little bit but not in a crucial way
we're gonna ignore that for right now
but we also have the photon field right
we have a new field if if we want to
have this gauge symmetry we need this
connection field the photon field it
needs to have its kinetic energy okay
and that we just need to invent from
scratch
so there's a long story that I'm gonna
make very very short the kinetic energy
of a gauge field which is the connection
right
what can I say comes from is made from
comes from well what could it possibly
come from what do you have when you have
a connection lying around if you
remember the video the idea that we did
on geometry connection is a way to
parallel transport things and by
parallel transporting something we find
out how it changes around a loop if
that's what we want to find and that
gives us something called the curvature
in space time it was called the Riemann
curvature tensor so guess what if you're
not a space time symmetry if you're an
internal symmetry there's still a
curvature you can still take that quark
field in red green blue space you can
try parallel transport it around a loop
it will be rotated in general you can
make that loop infinitesimally small and
you're going to construct a curvature
and the curvature unlike the connection
field itself is gauge invariant it is
something that can be written in a very
simple way it's gauge covariant
technically I am sorry I apologize for
all the technical footnotes here but I
want to talk to people who know this
stuff already and to people who don't it
transforms nicely under gauge
transformation so comes from the
curvature
I hope that's the right spelling of
curvature yes so to each connection is
associated curvature we can calculate it
it depends on the derivatives of the
connection and it depends on it in a way
that gives you a nice thing that
transforms nicely under gauge
transformations so you from that
curvature usually by taking the
curvature and squaring it you can
construct the kinetic energy for the
gauge field okay so for example in
electromagnetism I told you the
connection field is the photon field
what is the curvature what is the
curvature of the gauge field well it
equals the electromagnetic fields the E
and B fields this is the electric field
this is the magnetic field again Maxwell
didn't know about this Faraday didn't
know about this but now you do know
about it okay the electric field the
good old electric field the one you can
measure by having an a gal vomiter the
magnetic field that you can measure with
a compass these are the curvatures
associated with the connection that we
call the photon field it's all this
beautiful underlying geometric structure
okay so and the same thing is true for
gravity also this is the curvature of
space-time connection itself that gives
you the kinetic energy for gravity for
Einstein's theory of general relativity
what we call the einstein hilbert action
or the einstein Hilbert Lagrangian okay
so that was one way in which gauge
invariance helps us figure out what the
Lagrangian can be it figures out what
the kinetic energy of the gauge field
itself is what about up here that I
started this and then I got distracted
here okay so let's pick this the
electron field varying in that way I'm
gonna copy it I'm gonna paste it I'm
gonna make it bigger okay so this I
don't think it's what I wanted to do I'm
gonna paste it again there we go
okay what I just said here was that the
kinetic energy for the connection field
is basically determined by the
requirement of respecting the symmetry
respecting gauge invariance what I'm
going to tell you now is the potential
energies are also highly highly
constrained by the gauge invariance in
this case the potential energy of the
electron field itself so the electron
field potential energy what does that
mean well the potential energy depends
on the field but not its derivatives
okay so you might say you might guess
that there is a term in the Lagrangian
that looks like psy e - squared why not
that's you know sort of like the
equivalent of the simple harmonic
oscillator right x squared is the
potential energy in the simple harmonic
oscillator maybe there's a potential
energy that looks like the electron
field squared but under this symmetry
right cyi x goes to e to the I theta
sorry X so this would go to e to the 2i
theta sy e - squared so it's not
invariant it changes under this gauge
transformation we have to somehow do
better we can do better we know how to
do better I'm sort of going very slowly
here the obvious thing to do is sigh a -
squared with absolute value signs around
it right because that is sy e - complex
conjugate times ie - ok and that in fact
goes - under this gauge transformation e
to the minus I theta sy e - complex
conjugate e to the plus I theta
sy e - and then that equals oops I
shouldn't write the arrow I should write
equals e to the plus I theta near the
minus I theta cancel so you get sy e -
squared so this is invariant under gauge
transformations so this beast over here
turns out to not be good for kinetic
for potential energies in Lagrangian
this one is good and that has a dramatic
consequence because again for reasons
why Baraka to get into here if sigh II -
is the electron then the complex
conjugate sigh II - star creates
positrons
it's the anti particle the complex
conjugate is the anti particle of the
original particle that we started with I
should be able to draw a better size
than that I suppose I've drawn them
enough in my life I should get good at
it so what this means is terms like this
Sai star sigh can appear in Lagrangian
in fact for other complicated reasons
the real well sorry
so that can appear in Lagrangian so you
can get sy e - squared which is sign a -
star which is really the positron times
ie - this gives mass to the electron x
squared or Phi squared or size squared
is where the is the term in the
Lagrangian that corresponds to the mass
of the corresponding field okay there's
a longer story here with the weak
interactions etc but this is the thing
you can write down in quantum
electrodynamics there's no problem with
electrons being massive generally the
rule in quantum field theory is if
there's nothing if there's no symmetry
or principle that prevents something
from happening then it happens okay so
if the electron were massless you'd
expect there to be some symmetry that
prevented it from getting a mass but
there's not here we can write down a
mass term for the electron no problem we
can also write down an interaction term
there's a little more subtle and again
I'm glossing over some details but the
interaction looks like the same thing sy
star II - sy e - times gamma the photon
okay so this corresponds in Flyman
diagram language
to that vertex that we drew where a
photon comes in and how it goes an
electron and positron so the point is
that reason why I'm for this is a little
bit of detail here I know but the reason
why I wanted to go over it is you get a
immediate very powerful physical
implication of this gauge symmetry okay
we could write down determine the
Lagrangian that coupled a single photon
to an electron and a positron we could
not write down in a gauge invariant way
a term the coupled a single photon to
two electrons all by themselves two
electrons all by themselves would have
been this thing and that is forbidden
okay so gauge invariance the demand of
all the terms in your Lagrangian being
gauge invariant is enforcing the
conservation of electric charge gauge
invariance is the thing that says that
if you start with a neutral particle
like the photon if it's going to turn
into charged particles it will be an
equal number of positively charged and
negatively charged particles and that's
a reflection remember of northers
theorem northers theorem said that when
there's a symmetry there is a conserved
quantity the conserved quantity
associated with u1 the gauge invariance
of the vector magnetic field is charged
is electric charge and you can see that
at the level of the Lagrangian the level
of the terms you can write down the
define your effective field theory so
long story short two big things just
happened three big things have happened
so far in this in this video one is
there exists ways of having gauge Theory
symmetries gauge symmetries that can
separately rotate things at different
points in space the price you pay or if
you like the benefit you get there's a
new field you need the connection and
that connection gives rise to a force of
nature
second thing is you can calculate the
curvature of that connection and use
that to define the kinetic energy of the
connection field so the Lagrangian the
equations of motion if you like for the
connection field itself is strongly
constrained just by gauge invariance and
you use the curvature to get there third
you can also constrain the the
Lagrangian associated with the matter
feels with the the electrons or the
equivalent things to say about quarks
and so forth so the set of interactions
you can get in your theory and whether
or not you can get a mass for your
particles is also highly constrained by
gauge invariants so you can see how you
know why physicists fall in love with
this not only does gauge invariance give
rise to the forces it's an
extraordinarily powerful constraint on
what can happen in physical interactions
and that's exactly what physicists like
you know we don't have an infinite set
of possibilities to think about we have
a very very constrained set of
possibilities okay there's a final
consequence so we talked about what do
we talk about we talked about the
kinetic energy of the gauge field we
said the kinetic energy of the matter
fields of the electrons just sort of
goes along for the ride there's a little
bit of a change there but it's not a big
deal we talked about the potential
energy of the matter fields and that is
affected by gauge invariance you can
give it a mass but it involves the
positron as well as the electron and
also the interactions another that's
another kind of potential energy because
it does not involve any derivatives of
anything is also highly constrained by
gauge invariants what are we left with
well we're left with the potential
energy of the gauge field right because
we did the kinetic energy we did all the
others right so what about the potential
energy of the gauge field the first
thing you might want to write down so if
the if the photon field is gamma of X
can you write down
can you guess gamma squared okay
gamma the photon field despite the fact
that it is carrying it is sort of
conveying information about the
complex-valued electron fields gamma is
help as a real field is not complex it
does not get rotated under gauge
transformations that's not what happens
to it under gauge transformations and
under u 1 gauge transformations
there is something that happens to the
photon fuel gamma of X oops gamma X goes
to gamma of X plus derivatives I'll
write a little funny D sign for
derivatives of theta so theta the unk
transformation itself is e to the I
theta of X remember a separate little
rotation at every point in space and
theta itself is what enters the gauge
transformation of the photon field now
you might worry because up here I wrote
a gamma and it looks like that would
change but it's compensated by other
terms in the Lagrangian that's why I
didn't go into it in detail so that so
forget I ever said that
think about this the point is this gas
is wrong right this would go under gauge
transformations to gamma plus derivative
of theta squared and that is not a
variant that's just some messy thing
it's not that messy it's a its gamma
squared plus 2 D theta gamma plus D
theta squared we can do that we can do
that much math anyway it's not a variant
changes into something else so you
cannot write down a mass term for the
photon there's no there's no equivalent
of taking the complex conjugate to get
rid of it because it transforms in a
different way
under the gauge transformation so that's
it that's the correct result from this
the answer is gauge bosons as we call
them the particles that correspond to
the connection field that comes from the
gauge symmetry are massless that is a
result of gauge invariance okay that's
why the photon is massless you've been
wondering since we started talking about
photons why are photons massless why
can't they have a mass this is why
because photons are the gauge bosons of
symmetry and that symmetry prohibits the
term and Lagrangian that would give them
a mass so this is a feature of gauge
symmetries that the bosons associated
with them are
just massless this is enormous ly useful
this has giant implications the massless
nests of the photon to me it's
intrinsically
interesting right the photons are
massless I already told you the theorem
that says that things need to be as
complicated as possible so this is not
the end of the story but it is a very
important part of the story the examples
where the photon the the gauge bosons
are obviously massless are photons and
also gravitons people sometimes wonder
like you know you never seen a graviton
etc if you if you've been following this
far all the ideas videos we haven't gone
into general relativity and gravity just
yet but general tivity is a field theory
and quantum mechanics is out there so
it's going to be a quantum field theory
at some point there is already an
effective field here you can write down
for general relativity and that just
predicts the existence of gravitons we
haven't observed them directly but if
you don't believe in gravitons you have
to undo something absolutely fundamental
about the nature of quantum mechanics
itself you can try to do that good luck
with that but the rest of us sorry is
gonna believe that gravitons exists even
if we haven't observed them yet so
photons and gravitons because of this
gauge invariance that we cannot write
down a mass term for the Lagrangian and
therefore they have zero mass and this
gives rise to Coulomb's law for photons
and Newton's law for gravity that is to
say when you have some let's say you
have an electric charge okay the fact
that photons are massless that this is
not very respectable what about to say
but it gets you the right answer and
it's close enough to being respectable
very roughly speaking the fact that
photons are massless says we can make
them meet implies that we can make them
without any cost okay you can make an
arbitrarily low energy photon the energy
of a photon can be as low as you want
energy goes like you know e equals H F
the frequency can be as small as you
want giving rise to a low energy photon
as low energy as you want so from an
electron
there will be lines of electromagnetic
force coming out okay in all three
dimensions and if you draw a sphere of
radius R around electron these lines of
force go out they don't end they just go
out forever because it doesn't cost any
energy to make these photons and
therefore the density of lines of force
goes down as the area of the sphere
this sphere here the sphere has an area
that is proportional to R squared and
therefore the density of lines of force
goes down as 1 over R squared and
therefore the force is proportional to 1
over R squared that's true both for
electromagnetism and for gravity and
it's true for the same reason in both
cases in both cases these are forces
that are mediated by massless bosons and
massless means the lines of force never
end because you can just make a particle
of arbitrarily low energy you can
stretch out there so massless gauge
bosons seem to give rise to force laws
that goes 1 over R squared it seems to
be just a geometric fact right so on the
one hand this is a great triumph for
this whole story I've been telling you
because we've explained we say now that
we've explained both why
electromagnetism and why gravity obey
more or less 1 over R squared force laws
we know that in general 2v that's not
quite right because general relativity
is a non abelian gauge theory so there
are couplings between gravitons but
still in the solar system this is
extremely close to a very good
approximation the problem with this is
that it doesn't seem to hold true for
the weak and strong nuclear forces the
nuclear forces are short-range they are
not proportional to 1 over R squared
there's no Coulomb law for the strong
force or for the weak force and in the
1950s everyone knew this stuff like this
is the story I've just told you was know
you know when yang-mills proposed
yang-mills theories this we thought we
understood
magnetism in the 1950s QED right quantum
electrodynamics we thought we understood
gravity at least classically general
relativity the strong and weak nuclear
forces were still mysteries
so in yang and Mills proposed that you
could make gauge theories with non
abelian gauge fields with rotations that
did not commute with each other everyone
could instantly say well that would give
rise to massless bosons and we haven't
observed those that would give rise to
long-range forces and the strong weak
nuclear forces are not long-range what
is going on well something is going on
in both the strong nuclear force and the
weak nuclear force and again because of
the theorem that says things need to be
as complicated as possible what's going
on in those two cases is completely
different so we have to examine in
different ways the strong nuclear force
and the weak nuclear force okay so let's
think about the strong force the strong
force QCD right quantum chromodynamics
is an su3 gauge theory we're the three
is the three colors right su three color
red green and blue rotating the quarks
together so this is non abelian and what
that means is that the rotations in
color space do not commute with each
other rotating around green and then red
is not the same as we're taking about
red and then green what that means for
reasons I'm not gonna get into right now
oh yeah you haven't yet to trust me
sometimes I'm doing my best to give you
the concepts but things get messy very
quickly what that means is that unlike
photons photons are not themselves
electrically charged okay photons carry
the electromagnetic force between
charged particles but they're not
themselves electrically charged so
photons this is a little parentheses
here photons can do this you can have a
photon come in and give you an electron
and a positron but not a photon coming
in and giving you two photons okay I
need to sort of X that out because this
is not allowed photon is not coupled to
itself because the photons not itself
electrically charged but
quarks or sorry gluons oops that's not
what I wanted
gluons do change non-trivial D under su3
there's eight gluons and they all very
very roughly speaking you can think of
the gluon as a combination of a color in
an anti color like red and anti blue or
something like that doesn't quite work
because if you count that way you get
nine different gluons and there are only
eight but roughly speaking that works
but the point is gluons are them sell
themselves colored in a very real way
so gluons can do this where here's a
gluon that's a photon this is a gluon a
gluon can make a quark and an antiquark
this is Q anti quark okay if the gluon
itself were red anti blue one of the
quarks might be red the other cork the
anti quark might be anti blue for
example and you can have a gluon come in
and coupled to two other gluons just
like that that is something that can
happen in this non abelian gauge theory
that doesn't happen in ordinary
electromagnetism that's one feature it's
non abelian so it can couple to itself
non abelian means couple sorry should be
tell you what couples gauge fields
couple to themselves gauge fields in
this case the gluon couple to themselves
unlike in you one electromagnetism the
other feature is something called
asymptotic freedom this is really I mean
this is really the payoff lecture here
in many ways the payoff video because
we're bringing in all these ideas from
different other idea videos that we've
done remember we talked about in the
video about renormalization we could put
a cut-off on our theory to get an
effective field theory we admit that we
don't know what goes on above the cutoff
the price you pay for that is that the
coupling constants in your low energy
effective field theory depend on the
value of the cuddles okay so you can ask
as you change the cutoff how does the
effective value of the coupling
constants change one example would be in
QED this is not an example of asymptotic
freedom yet but this is good old
ordinary quantum electromagnetism as you
have the energy going higher and higher
what happens to alpha the fine-structure
constant the answer is that it goes up
like that to get stronger and stronger
we even do the little picture of the
electron being renormalized by a cloud
of virtual particles right I give some
physical understanding of what's going
on why the effective coupling
electromagnetism is stronger at shorter
distances therefore higher energies so
it turns out there's a calculation you
can do in the strong interactions in QCD
call it alpha strong the strong
interaction version of the
fine-structure constant you can ask how
does it change with energy and the
answer is it does this it goes down okay
this is the phenomenon known as
asymptotic freedom it's not an easy
calculation to do david gross frank will
check david Politzer did it in the early
nineteen seventies they won the Nobel
Prize for doing it it's really that's it
that's why they won the Nobel Prize the
curve goes down stead of going up a -
line instead of a plus sign but it's not
obvious it depends on all the fields all
their interactions you have to actually
work it out okay and what that means is
high energy means a weak coupling so
that's why it's called asymptotic
freedom freedom means not interacting at
all free
don't interact okay so this is saying
that if you really push the particles to
very very high energies the interaction
stops being strong that's it's weakly
coupled you can use Fineman diagrams
everything is great but as you let the
energies go lower and lower as you
settle down rather than smashing
particles together in high energies you
just let them sit there the coupling
becomes stronger and stronger if you
have particles moving and hitting each
other at very low energies so there is a
value here an energy below which the
coupling is about one remember the whole
point the wonderful thing about the
fine-structure constant even though I
drew it changing by a lot here it's
always pretty small 1 over 137 had very
very low energies and not that much
different in high energies so in the
strong interactions below a certain
energy and that energy works out to be
about 0.3 GeV okay but a third of a GeV
remember a GeV is the mass of the proton
or the mass of a neutron below that
energy the strong interactions are so
strong when you can't even really use
Fineman diagrams anymore you can't use
perturbation theory the theory is just
SuperDuper strongly coupled these quarks
are really interacting with each other
and the gluons are interacting with each
other a lot that by the way is the
reason why the proton is about 1 GeV
because there are 3 quarks and we
remember I told you in the sorry if you
watched the video on scale but then also
watched the Q&A video in the scale video
I talked about the mass of the proton
being 1 GeV only in the Q&A video for
scale that I revealed that the quarks
that make up the proton are much less
than a third of a GeV there are only a
few times more massive than the electron
ok the up and down quarks it's the
energy of the interactions of the
quantum chromodynamics interactions that
give rise to the mass of the proton and
that's this energy times 3 1/3 of a GeV
times 3 is 1 GeV that's the mass of the
proton the reason why the proton is a is
about 1 GeV and mass is because there
are three quarks in it and each quark is
surrounded by this energy from gluons
up to about point three GeV and there
are three of them that's where you get
that mass has nothing to do with the
mass of the individual quarks themselves
and what this means is as synthetic
freedom means as you get to higher
energies the interaction goes away you
get the lower energies the interaction
becomes stronger and stronger and what
that means is confinement so quarks if
you have two quarks if you just simplify
your life and just imagine there are two
quarks interacting with each other so
here you have a quark here you have
another quark okay and there there's
some gluons between them so they're
interacting with gluons and there's a
lot of them because they're strongly
interacting so a lot of them and you try
to pull them apart okay so you try to
pull apart the quarks what's gonna
happen is not that they just get further
and further apart like an electron and
proton you just pull apart no big deal
what's happening is these gluons become
more and more energetic to the point
where they there's so much energy in the
gluons then you can just create more
quarks so what happens is actually you
just create here's a quark you create an
anti quark oops
you create a quark antiquark pair in the
middle that here that you're the two
quark you started with here's the quark
here's the anti quark and now you have a
quark
talking to that quark and this anti
quark talking to the other quark that
you started with so when you try to pull
apart a quark two quarks to get
individual quarks out there all by
themselves it will never happen
literally never happen it's not that you
haven't tried hard enough you pull them
apart it's like pulling a rubber band
apart you never get only one ended
rubber band you just split it in the
middle and you get two new ends it's
much like the magnetic monopole store
you cut a magnet with the North and
South Pole you don't get a North Pole
all by itself you get a north and a
South Pole on both of them so
confinement is and this is because as
you stretch things out remember longer
distances is lower energies lower
energies the coupling is stronger and
stronger so you never get a quark all by
itself and what that means is
you know instead of this nice Coulomb
force with lines of force going out you
might think well I have a quark this is
what you might think you'd be wrong and
I have lines of force from gluons going
in all directions right so I should get
a 1 over R squared inverse square law
force but in fact the gluons themselves
are interacting with each other all over
the place right I can't even draw it
nearly realistically enough it's a mess
and the whole thing can fines together
into a ball and no gluons escape to the
outside world that is confinement and
the size is around this QCD scale so
that's why in the case of the strong
interactions the forces are short ranged
because rather than lines a force going
out infinitely far the lines of force
interact with each other and they bundle
up into a ball of yarn that forms a
proton or a neutron or a Payan or
something like that
all those are massive particles and
there's no massless particles that you
can actually observe in QCD so gluons
and QCD are massless because we showed
the gauge theory implies that bosons are
massless right that the gauge bosons are
massless but they are confined so you
never see them so there's no long-range
1 over R squared force that's how the
strong interactions work still got the
weak interactions is the final bit of
the puzzle the weak interactions ok this
is a longer story not going to get to it
in any detail but the problem with the
weak interactions not the problem the
feature is that there's an su 2 gauge
symmetry but it is broken spontaneously
broken by a little field we call the
Higgs the Higgs boson field
and let me just give you the briefest of
glossary of what that actually means so
there's an su 2 symmetry okay that means
two dimensional space two complex
dimensions so really four dimensions so
it's kind of hard to draw those really
four dimensions but two complex
dimensions okay
so let's let's stretch our imaginations
a little bit and draw the to demand the
two directions in higgs space but the
call it you know h1 and h2 but keeping
in mind that both h1 and h2 the two
directions of Higgs field space are both
complex okay and so what happens is this
is the there this sort of for a four
dimensional space of Higgs bosons but
what happens is in the early universe
the Higgs boson settles down and gets a
nonzero vac value in the vacuum in empty
space so you might think that if you
have some fields there minimum energy
state is near zero value for the field
so let's let's back up a little bit
let's uh draw in a slightly different
way if we draw the potential energy here
okay so now we're gonna draw the the
potential energy of the Higgs field
which is a function of hey h1 and h2 two
complex valued fields okay there's h1
there's h2 you might think one possible
way could have been was that you get a
potential that looks more or less like
this our famous simple harmonic
oscillator potential okay and then what
that means is that the Higgs would just
sit there at the bottom and everything
would be great the symmetry would be
respected by which we mean you could
rotate h1 and h2 into each other su 2
rotations and that field value would be
unchanged it would not do anything by
doing that
however that's not how nature works that
ain't it that's not what's actually
happening so in fact let me erase this
thing which is fine but I can do better
here's what what actually happens you
again are gonna do field space oops
that's not right
so you're gonna do potential energy here
is one part of the Higgs field here's
the other part of the Higgs field h2 is
the potential energy as a function of h1
and h2 and this is just a fact about how
nature works you know the potential
energy for the Higgs field doesn't look
like this drawing on the Left what it
looks like is what we call a Mexican hat
potential I do not know why they don't
just call it a sombrero potential they
never asked me for some reason particle
physicists like to call this the Mexican
hat potential okay it's symmetric around
rotations with respect to rotations of
h1 and h2 that's it needs to be
symmetric this this rotation in this
direction is the SU 2 symmetry of the
weak interaction so it needs to be
symmetric but the lowest energy state is
not at h1 equals 82 equals 0 the lowest
energy state is the brim of the Hat at
some non-zero value so the Higgs field
in the early universe would have started
out here okay it would started out near
zero but then it would have fallen into
the brim of the Hat as the universe
expanded and cooled down the Higgs field
goes down to the bottom where you know
where along the brim of the Hat does it
live doesn't matter
completely symmetric right that's the
whole point in fact there's literally no
difference between it going to h1 or h2
or anywhere in between you can always do
a rotation so it goes wherever you want
the point is it goes somewhere oops the
point is it goes somewhere and that
breaks the symmetry the symmetry is
still there since symmetry is still
underlying the dynamics of everything
but now you can ask yourself the
question am i pointing in the direction
of the actual direction the Higgs field
is pointing or am i perpendicular to the
Higgs field so even though this theory
itself has a symmetry the low-energy
manifestation of the theory does not
because low energies means small tiny
oscillations and you're either in the
direction of the Higgs field or you're
not ok so there's something that breaks
the set
the tree between all these different
values so in in yet other words you can
you can think about it this way if here
is space and you have remember let's say
the up door up quark and down quark a
little doublet su 2 doublet an su 2
symmetry that rotates these two guys
into each other so that means that if it
weren't for this Higgs getting in the
way
there'd be no difference between the up
quark and the down quark but now at
every point in space there is a Higgs
field pointing in some direction in SU 2
space not in physical space not an
up-down left-right space but in SU 2
space okay and that's true everywhere so
now you can ask are you the quark that
is pointing parallel to the Higgs or
perpendicular to the things okay and
that breaks the symmetry that is why
they are different and also long story
short you can have an interaction just
like you had this interaction way back
up here where was it that yes you can
have an interaction between the photon
the electron and the positron likewise
very similarly even though you could not
have an interaction between the gauge
bosons and themselves to give a mass you
can have an action interaction between
the gauge balls let's call let's say the
Z boson Z complex conjugate times Z
times the Higgs this isn't allowed
interaction and the Higgs field becomes
just a constant value this little number
here for some reason that value of the
Higgs field is called little V so this
turns into little V times Z Z star and
that is a mass term for Z boson there's
a very similar thing going on for the W
boson so the mass of the W and Z bosons
is around 80 or 90 GeV 80 or 90 times
the mass of the proton
so they're heavy that's one of the
reasons why the weak interactions are
hard to notice it's hard to make a z
boson and the other thing is that rather
than the force law for photons where is
it blue photons the force law 1 is 1
over R squared there's really it's hard
to imagine what else it could have gone
as there's there's arguments ok but but
that's a very natural thing for it to do
the force law for the weak interactions
for the W or Z bosons is proportional to
e to the minus the distance over the
Compton wavelength of the W or Z bosons
remember the Compton wavelength is just
1 over the mass so this is e to the
minus the mass of the W or Z bosons
times the distance so the force law
rather than going is 1 over R squared it
goes as e to the minus arm which is very
very quickly going to 0 so that's why
the weak interactions are short range
this is part of the scale discussion
that didn't quite have time to do this
is another way that masses get related
to distances because the mass is just 1
over the Compton wavelength and
basically if you imagine you're a little
quark you're an up quark okay and you're
trying to give off W bosons in some
different directions to create force law
it takes energy to make those W bosons
they're not massless there's a lot of
wolfs that are required so roughly
speaking you can push them out lambda W
which is 1 over the mass of the W which
is not very big at all I mean sorry M W
is big so lambda W the Compton
wavelength of the W is very very short
so the weak interactions are not only
weak they're also very very short-range
this is why it's hard to notice them
here is the big picture okay I know this
was a lot it's a lot to do on the one
hand as a payoff lecture but on the
other hand is a lot of concepts going on
I get that so the point is that gauge
theories
have phases completely different use of
the word phase than eally i theta phase
that we talked about before here I'm
talking about phase in the same sense as
we talked about water being liquid or
gas or solid ice right different phases
different ways that the physics the
physical properties of the substance can
manifest themselves even though the same
underlying dynamics are going on the a
gauge Theory can be in the Coulomb phase
and there that's when you have free
massless well I shouldn't say free free
implies non interacting this is this is
free free in a different sense of the
word free Friesen allowed to propagate
all by themselves
not confined okay free massless gauge
bosons and that leads to a force law F
proportional to one over R squared okay
this is for gravity this is for
electromagnetism
that's one phase that a gauge theory can
be in the confined phase so here you
have confined massless gauge bosons and
their gluons QCD would be an example the
force law is a little bit trickier it's
again an exponential fall off but the
point is it's not the gluons themselves
that are escaping out and creating the
forces forces between protons and
neutrons can be modeled as exchanging pi
ons back and forth between them but even
that's not a perfect model it's really
that if you get a proton a neutron
together they form a six quark bound
state they're no longer the identity of
the proton the neutron by themselves is
not separately conserved but it's all
blob together is a bunch of quarks and
so to talk about the range and the force
law with respect to the strong
interactions it's a tricky thing to do
most people just don't even try finally
there's the Higgs fades
and that's where you get broken symmetry
and massive it's not very elegant
massive gauge bosons so on the one hand
yeah life is complicated
we have su3 the strong interactions QCD
we have su 2 and we have u 1 also
gravity they're all there in all the
different phases are actually realized
there's there's other phases you can
imagine talking about but these are the
main ones for gauge theories so Nature
has chosen to give us a bounty of
different possible physical situations
going on
that's why physics is hard but that's
also why physics is fun I'm hoping I'm
not sure this is true but the hope at
the end of this long disquisition is
that the underlying ideas remain clear
there's a lot of details here and
because the world is full of details in
the details matter
but the underlying ideas are actually
very simple and beautiful the existence
of a symmetry that is separately
realizable at different points in space
implies the existence of a new field
that tells you how to relate what's
going on at these different points in
space that field the connection field
gives rise to gauge bosons these Keys BH
bosons can appear in different phases
and that explains everything we know
about all the forces of nature in any
experiment we've ever done so far
there's no force of nature we don't know
that we know about that cannot be
explained by one of these different
realizations of the gauge symmetry
underlying things so hopefully you get
why the combination of geometry and
symmetry is so important it explains an
enormous amount about how we understand
the real world